el gobierno alemán ha reiterado en
muchas ocasiones y lo hizo también en el
marco de esta reunión en Rammstein que
no dejará de apoyar a Ucrania que lo
hará por el tiempo que sea necesario
pero para Ucrania y para algunos de los
otros aliados de Alemania esa ayuda en
la actualidad no está siendo suficiente
y el debate se centra en el envío o no
de los tanques leopard que Ucrania pide
que algunos países quisieran enviar aquí
es pero cuya aprobación final depende de
Alemania de las autoridades en Berlín
como lugar de origen de esos tanques
Alemania ha explicado que ordenó la
revisión de las existencias y de la
disponibilidad de esos tanques que
quisiera coordinar con sus aliados que
quisiera evitar decisiones unilaterales
pero lo cierto Es que este debate sobre
los tanques de leopardo está poniendo
muchísima presión no solamente sobre el
nuevo ministro de la defensa alemán que
no lleva ni una semana en el cargo sino
de manera más general en el canciller
Alemán Olaf sols soles ha reiterado en
muchas ocasiones el rol que juega
Alemania apoyando a Ucrania pero para
algunos de sus críticos se trata de un
canciller reticente en momentos en que
debería tomar un liderazgo mucho mayor
cuando se trata de apoyar a Ucrania